the Joe Rogan experience sober October's
over but we can we were allowed to smoke
cigars during silver October for
whatever reason but they do get you high
they do give you a nice little buzz they
do yeah it's weird that that's like
thought of us being a sobriety thing is
it really I mean if you're smoking
people smoke cigarettes when they're
sober yeah all those [ __ ] AAA guys
right those guys were always those guys
will tell you you can't have a
non-alcoholic beer which I do I haven't
done a I've been out of tree it'll be
[ __ ] 30 years next month that I
haven't had a drink didn't you have like
one or two when me need I may need I had
some Scotch that's a weird one right I
had like I didn't get drunk but I had
like a few shots did you like feel weird
about that I've been all those years I
think I felt so weird about him being
dead that the whole thing felt surreal
anyway and I haven't really haven't had
the desire I can't say heck can't doubt
the desire it's more of just like you
you feel like there's times where you
want to just do what everybody else is
doing and just chill out and you see
everybody getting more mellow and
relaxed and social and especially if I'm
in a situation where you know it's a
bunch of people I don't know that well
maybe it's your kids friends parents
itchin nice glass of wine edge off dude
dude but she did the the couple glasses
of scotch and then you didn't go right
back to it
alright you became a 21 year old drunk
Greg again right well a lot of rats do
with my father and he was an alcoholic
and I saw I saw his depression the I the
same depression as he does and I felt I
felt like when I drank it wasn't always
for fun it was a lot of times it was
like dealing with feelings and [ __ ]
like that and so I saw him as an unhappy
guy who was unfulfilled in a lot of ways
and I saw the alcohol was
part of why his life wasn't but it could
have been right and I just sort of feel
like you know maybe maybe I could drink
but maybe I can't why [ __ ] with it know
why [ __ ] with it I'll tell you what
ma'am I just got done with a whole month
of being sober and then I had my first
drinks this weekend I felt like [ __ ] no
kidding felt like [ __ ] yeah I had a
couple of glasses of wine went to play
pool and I was having a hard time
focusing on the ball the balls like
three glasses of wine yeah that's all it
takes three glasses of wine I'm having a
hard time seeing all right it took like
cuz everything's all just a little off
it took like an hour before my liver
processed it enough where I could play
pool well again do you think you just
lost your your tolerance tolerance yeah
for sure
yeah I mean I never never been a big
drinker anyway but it was interesting
doing sets that's what's always
interested it sound like a shot before I
go onstage I always like to do a shot of
Jack yeah we're going to say just whoa
that's amazing for you a little bit of
whiskey
Wow big show just one shot yeah yeah
Brian Regan one shot of frozen
peppermint schnapps before he goes
there's peach schnapps I give you like
this okay yeah yeah but it's not
necessary no no it's definitely not I
mean I did a lot of shows this month
stone cold sober but it's um
isn't it weird though the human
condition that we're born with this set
of you know this brain and this these
neurological pathways and this
relationship to the universe and the
people around us and that we want to
whether it's smoking pot or drinking or
taking opiates we want to change the
natural state of our brain yeah isn't
that [ __ ] weird
because it's all we talk about all
people talk about do what us we dude we
got [ __ ] up I changed my brain I made
myself dumber all week and I made myself
dumber did a bunch of stupid [ __ ] I
should have never done stupid [ __ ] yeah
because in our natural state we don't do
goofy [ __ ] enough but then I learned
when I
quit drinking that I could be just as
crazy people don't realize I quit I've
been hanging out my same friends in the
same bars till 4:00 in the morning we'd
go to a wedding I'd be the last guy on
the dance floor first guy on the dance
floor and I just was like you know this
doesn't have to change me you know yeah
you can just enjoy fun you just enjoyed
fun it takes a little bit more of I
think you have to sort of break through
walls a little bit more as opposed to
just the booze does that for you yeah
but you can still get there
[Applause]